[Music]
hey what's going on everybody for first
we feast I'm Sean Evans coming at you
from Bowery Meat Company in the East
Village where I'm joined by Andrew
Steven and of course a spot for camera
guy Adam though the guys behind
BuzzFeed's tremendously popular series
worth it
where they eat their way around the
globe in hopes of answering the only
question that really matters when it
comes to food is it worth the price and
today we're gonna be putting the
corporate card to good use
focusing on some of the most coveted
sought-after and yes very expensive cuts
of beef in New York City but before we
get to the taste test I have to know you
guys are now three seasons into the show
of all the things that were not worth it
what's been the biggest ripoff I
wouldn't say that any place has been an
outright ripoff we've eaten some really
ridiculous things you know like a two
thousand dollar pizza it's crazy that's
an insane amount of money spent on any
food item but if you were going to buy
that you know what you're doing you know
you're getting into you know the terrain
so you can't write all it a ripoff it's
almost like a dare like can you get it
this expensive and make it actually
worth it some of them I was like into
blowing a lot of money at a casino just
like yeah you know what I'm gonna have a
lobster self with mac and cheese I'm
just gonna like spray a bunch of money
on this and like it's gonna be a weird
fun time for the people it's just a Ric
Flair situation sometimes you just gotta
pop that bottle right whoo for some
people she yeah well I can sit and
chitchat
all day but we have steaks to eat chef
Josh Capon is bringing out some of the
best cuts in New York City
chef Josh we're ready for the steaks all
right where we started with over here
look at this beauty we don't know what
that is right right here we have the
t-bone Florentines 40 ounce dry aged
$148 a little bit of extra-virgin olive
oil we're up up a little bit of sage
rosemary and thyme really get those
earthy flavors going charred on the
broiler let it rest slice it up and
that's it there's a New York Strip on
one side and you have a nice chunk of
filet on the other side so some people
like to say it's the best of both worlds
you serve all dry aged meat here at the
berry me company when you dry aged meat
there's two things that happens to meat
right first your evaporating the the
water from the mussel which concentrates
the flavor right your country in the
flavor and the intensity of the meat and
also the natural enzymes in the meat
break down the muscle so you're yielding
a much more tender piece of meat I'm
gonna let you guys enjoy the t-bone I
got something else working in the back
I'll bring out a few minutes all right
Thank You chef thank you so we're
looking at 148 dollars on the cut what
are you thinking first of all is a lot
of meat you can spread this out amongst
a couple people very easily I would say
with the dry aging I feel like in a lot
of ways you're really kind of going
through the whole cow's life maybe for
some people too close or like to
intimate experience with me it is
interesting and kind of weird that
you're now investing time host death in
an animal I'm always down to have
something that's less quantity than what
it started off as it's more intense and
rich Adam is this a nice departure from
the norm getting that fresh on the plate
thing you know we haven't even shot any
beauties yeah it feels wrong I pretty
like I feel like I need to get back
there and be documenting this check this
out this is something very very very
special and to be honest you are the
first people that we've served this to
over the by army company this is a
Chateaubriand the Chateaubriand refers
to the center cut of the filet mignon
also known as the beef tenderloin here
we serve it on the bone 40-day dry-aged
we prepare this with nothing more than
just kosher salt and black pepper nice
high heat on the grill and then you
really got to let it rest and it's a
slow cook in the oven and we got some
black and Cipollini onions with
see that little nugget right there every
state has room I like the cold another
to Joy see that you never stood on a
filet mignon normally you get a filet
mignon and it's a boring chunk of meat
not a lot of fat extremely tender and
not a lot of flavor by keeping this on
the bowl and you can see that and then
fat is flavor okay nobody ate me they'd
be like wow this guy's like a flavor
bomb for me I notice about the way
you're cutting these is you're getting
really thick with the cuts which I love
is there a reason why you go with that
thickness I I think the meat deserves to
become thick you know you want it you
want the characteristic of the meat you
know you want to be able to chew it you
know this is good meat if this was if
this was a low quality steak I mean you
could shave a little quality steak on a
slicer when it's frozen and when you
cook it are you short a it it's gonna be
tender no matter what because there's no
chance of any fat or veins or muscles
being left of it I'll be back in a
little bit with the biggest and baddest
and best date yet all right so here we
have a juicier steak and then on a price
point level going down a little bit 125
bucks for this one but you could share
this among you know we're sharing among
four people 25 not bad
filet mignon it's you know it has that
it has that place as sort of the the
gold standard of meals and then you go
to a couple of weddings where you get
filet mignon and all of a sudden the
experience has been completely ruined
for you because you just get that Drive
wedding filet mignon it is crazy how
much flavor is in this like so intent
I'm almost uncomfortable with how soft
this is it's like approaching cotton
candy softness
[Music]
the greatest stake known to mankind
under that beautiful thing huh all right
this is the 40-day 40 ounce dry aged
tomahawk rib eye $162 as good as it gets
we give this little extra age when it
comes into the shop we seize it with
kosher salt black pepper nice high heat
on the broiler let it rest finish it on
a boiler based a little bit of dry aged
beef fat and we service a little romesco
sauce and some charred onions that is
what we call a Tomahawk Chop they
brought the Souris chopped is that a lot
of beautiful thing
great presentation I just walk around
the dining room with these things
sometimes I threaten people they don't
pay their check they get whacked Oh God
let me ask you right now is it worth it
Oh his eyes are rolling from the back of
his head over there the rib eye if I
have a cracked that's the most expensive
steak on the menu here at Bowery this
why well it's the best it's it's the
most marble it's a rich it it's the most
decadent I mean these things there's not
that many in each cow so you got to make
them count plus you know I need all the
man pointed I can get so I like the idea
of just carrying around the bone it's
like Lord of the Flies right you only
get to speak unless you're holding the
conch here at the battery company unless
you olden time although he pays
attention to you
sometimes I walk around the streets with
the - you get a lot of respect joyful
thank you thank you I'm trying to think
of like what it felt like when I ate
that first bite like what experience
that was just so overwhelming that I
can't say anything it's like if you had
never been held in your life before it's
like oh just hold me
I'll hold in pain and you're just crying
because it's
it's so beautiful Josh send a hug to my
mouth through this neat I guess gross
we've had the t-bone we've had the
Chateaubriand we've had the tomahawk
which one was your favorite
I think the Chateau the way it was
prepared here where it's on the bone
there's that little extra piece of meat
that was awesome
I've never had anything like that and
you kind of ruined it because I also
have to go said like I feel crazy saying
that but that second steak the softness
of that was just an experience I've
never had before you're entering like
cannibal territory like is that this egg
was that the gateway drug to eating
people I hope not it caught me by
surprise too because the same way that
the wedding experience is ruined the
filet mignon for me I've always liked
like it had that billing but then too I
think that it's like probably the steak
with the least flavor generally speaking
but not that one not that Chateaubriand
how much was ribeye I got it
okay here's that's gonna play a role in
this okay
the chef the Chateaubriand 125 uh-huh
the t-bone 148 and then the ribeye
tamakwa by 160 to an additional forty
bucks to get the very first time in your
life well yeah worth it I would say it
is the tomahawk rib eye well there you
have it
catch worth it Sunday's 8:00 a.m. on
BuzzFeed guys happy we could get you
lunch thanks for coming through this is
lunch there's like six lunch
that's the shot of the wild difference
right there
[Music]
you
you